as an actor it's very different than
kind of the rest of it but it was always
you know be kind work very hard
Zelda Williams revealing to ET the best
advice for late father Robin Williams
gave her as an actor I think the concept
of ego has kind of taken over for a lot
of people in our industry where they
think what they're presenting has to be
a particular thing for them and
truthfully you're not your audience
so all that self-consciousness and all
of that it gets in the way of you
actually just being the best thing and
whatever thing that you're doing
meanwhile her father's work stands the
test of time with patch Adams
celebrating its 20th anniversary in
December and Dead Poets Society hitting
30 years next June medicine law business
engineering he's a noble pursuits poetry
grown man love he's in what we stay
alive for really you know I'm part of
film you hope that the things that you
make make people happy for as long as
they can
ET was with the 29 year old actress at
the premiere of the TV movie she
directed shrimp at the 2018 Tribeca TV
festival at Spring Studios in New York
shrimp is actually about the daily lives
of dominatrixes who work in a
professional dominatrix then so it's
actually much more about what their
lives are like for them as friends or
with their families it's not as much
about the clientele which I think it's
been told quite a few times already the
reason I made it at all is I was
actually mistaken for a dominatrix in a
bar and I was curious as to why I didn't
know what had reminded him of them in me
so I went into a den I asked them if I
could shadow and I ended up shadowing it
down for a couple months to write this
and it was very interesting to see what
modern-day fetishism how its treated by
the outside world
and then what it's like on the inside
but against misconstrued as as sex work
when yes there are sexual elements but
they don't have sex with their clients
and illegal dominatrix and that's
prostitution and in a lot of states
that's illegal so the loophole that they
found is by not providing that they're
generally not doing anything illegal
the greatest thing about that world is
it's the most consenting one I've ever
been in you know people having so much
trouble understand
consent and I don't know why when in
this world it's written out in
triplicate they know exactly what's
gonna happen in the time period and the
money that they're spending they know
exactly what they're paying for and
every person present has consented for
exactly what's happening so when that's
such an issue right now in every other
aspect of the world they've had it down
for hundreds of years
[Music]